pues la razón principal según ellos es
para adelantar de manera urgente las
elecciones generales previstas para
finales de año al 28 de mayo que es
cuando hay convocadas elecciones
municipales y autonómicas en España esto
para acabar con una legislatura suicida
así se refirió a la legislatura de Pedro
Sánchez el presidente del partido vox
Santiago abascal según este las razones
son muchas y en concreto mencionó temas
por ejemplo de control migratorio a las
que achacó a la migración irregular a
las que achacó
atentados terroristas yihadistas en el
pasado y hace pocos meses en España así
como atacó leyes de derechos de las
personas trans o de derechos o de leyes
de reproducción sexual y libertad sexual
como la ley del solo sí es sí por las
que según abascal las mujeres en el país
han quedado desprotegidas algo a lo que
Pedro Sánchez contestó y recordó que vo
fue el único partido que en 2021 votó en
contra del pacto de estado contra la
violencia de género el candidato
propuesto como bien lo mencionabas
Ángela Ramón tamames ex militante del
partido comunista no pudo empezar a
hablar en esta moción de censura en la
que él es el candidato a la presidencia
hasta bien pasadas las dos horas y media
de debate puesto que empezaron Santiago
abascal el presidente de vox y las
réplicas de Pedro Sánchez este tamames
en su discurso también habló de varios
temas bastante inconexos los unos con
los otros entre los que mencionó los
incendios forestales que asolan al país
o la baja natalidad de España una moción
de censura que la mayoría de los grupos
parlamentarios tildan de Absurda y de
una pérdida de tiempo
marina Qué consecuencia puede tener esta
moción
del palacio Pues si sale adelante se
disolverían las Cortes y se convocarían
elecciones generales pero realmente las
opciones de que esto sea así son casi
nulas puesto que se espera que esta
moción solo consiga los votos a favor de
los 52 diputados del partido vox sin
embargo lo que sí está por definir es
como votará el principal partido de la
oposición el partido Popular de derecha
que ha dicho que se abstendrá y no que
va a votar en contra esta abstención
Sánchez la ha calificado de indecente y
el peso de la utilizaría de ser cierta y
mañana lo veremos de dejar la puerta
abierta para una posible coalición de
gobierno con los ultraderechistas a
finales de año en caso de que el PP no
tenga la suficiente votos para conseguir
la mayoría absoluta precisamente esto
mismo vox lo ha mencionado en su
discurso y se ha dirigido al partido
popular diciéndoles votemos juntos hoy
para entendernos mañana hasta el momento
de las seis mociones de censura que ha
habido en España solo una ha sido
exitosa de hecho fue en 2018 La que puso
en el gobierno a Pedro Sánchez y que
desbancó al entonces presidente del
gobierno del partido popular Mariano
rajoy el resultado de esta moción de
censura lo conoceremos mañana en el voto